do you reach for your purse on the first
date yes always
to show my fake kindness yes of course I
do it it's like a guilt thing I always
reach to like show them well okay the
other day I dug around in here I felt my
wallet and I just kept digging and he
was waiting for me to finish digging and
then he finally just paid but I wanted
him to think I was nice yes and then of
course they pull it out and I say oh are
you sure well are you sure is good if
they don't pay for it on the first date
just the first date I say no second I
just think that's weird third day we can
start talking about that what so you
okay first of all you you
you expect them to pay on the first date
but then by the third date you could
talk about them not paying so you want
them to be less invested as the date as
time goes on should it be the other way
around if anything that on the first
date when they don't even know you like
they're they're not gonna pay and then
but then as you start to have a
relationship now they are paying
wouldn't it wouldn't you expect that to
be the way that that evolves